cuéntenos qué significado tendría esta
eventual visita de pelosi a taiwán es un
desafío en qué consecuencias podría
estar pensando china
andrés buenas buenas noches y realmente
es algo muy importante
esto es una visita de una alta jerarquía
que vamos a tener en taiwán pero muestra
la ambigüedad que eeuu ha tenido para
con el conflicto por así decir pekín
taiwán en eeuu admite la existencia de
una sola china pero no deja que de
alguna forma se mancille en el
territorio taiwanés en este caso creo
que todo se ha propiciado por algo que
se dio hace muy pocos días la iniciativa
de eeuu y taiwán de una zona de comercio
libre que daría un tlc finalmente entre
taiwán y estados unidos todo esto ha
propiciado que
primero china haya incursionado varias
veces sobre el territorio aéreo de
taiwán y esto a
disparado también la visita que estamos
hoy justamente analizando ahora porque
la seguridad de pelosi durante su
trayecto hacia taiwán generada tanta
preocupación en eeuu bueno es muy buena
pregunta es la primera vez hoy estamos
viviendo los dos mundos diferentes a los
que vimos hace 25 años donde se dio una
visita muy parecida a la dea a la actual
no es el mismo eeuu y no es la misma
china eeuu es otro gobernado por otro
partido político y en otro modo de
relaciones exteriores lo mismo china
china ya dejó la etapa anterior de hace
25 años para hacer un país que está
teniendo un protagonismo diferente una
situación de relaciones internacionales
diferentes una asistencia a sus vecinos
diferentes y fundamentalmente una idea
imperialista que es totalmente diferente
hoy
este tipo de situaciones se están
viviendo porque el ministerio defensa de
china dijo que el ejército no se va a
quedar con los brazos cruzados estos a
que eeuu a honrar su promesa de que no
apoyar la independencia de taiwán ahí
viene uno de los problemas que estamos
teniendo la visita del velo si no es por
la independencia de taiwán es una
democracia que visita a otra democracia
como la democracia taiwanesa el problema
de países como lo es china que tiene
institucionalidad es muy débiles o de
alguna forma no tan presentes es que
consideran en general que cualquier tipo
de situación que se anómala a lo que
ellos proponen es un ataque
me parece que china le está dando una
dimensión demasiado importante a la
visita de pelosi que tiene todo el
derecho de visitar a otra localidad este
en forma autónoma bueno y qué pasaría
por ejemplo o qué mensaje envía a eeuu
si por el contrario pero si decide no ir
es teniendo en cuenta las advertencias
de beijing muy brevemente por favor
muy brevemente es muy importante un zoom
que podría existir ahora entre bailén y
el presidente de chiná en este momento
eso podría aflojar un poco las
situaciones entre entre estas dos
potencias que son importantes
indudablemente si eeuu no visita y deja
de lado la visita de pelosi
taiwán estando un mensaje claro que me
parece que muestra cierta debilidad por
otra parte si china gana esta contienda
e indudablemente dentro del marco de lo
que puede ser el proceso de ucrania y
rusia también estamos teniendo una
situación importante
taiwán es el tester para saber cuál es
el conflicto que se nos viene en futuros
días